like giant Stone monoliths PODS of sperm
whales sleep vertically in the water
column a totally otherworldly presence
their massive bodies floating in
suspended Grace
our oceans are filled with nearly a
hundred species of cetacean warm-blooded
air-breathing mammals like bottlenose
dolphins and orcas and humpback whales
but sperm whales are among the strangest
of this group
sperm whales are the largest toothed
predators in the world they live in
tight social groups and are one of the
most widely distributed marine mammals
on the planet
they live anywhere there is deep water
from the poles to the equator they
Venture deeper than almost any other
mammal plunging into the dark abyss in
search of their Elusive and giant squid
prey
they dive so deep their lungs collapse
and yet they can stay underwater for
nearly two hours
as they hunt travel and raise their
young sperm whales can be heard
communicating with other members of
their group
and they can hear each other hundreds or
even thousands of miles away because
sperm whales are louder than any other
animal
their clicks are so loud that they can
easily blow out a human eardrum some say
they could even vibrate a human body to
death
free divers who interact with these
whales are completely at their Mercy
hoping and praying they don't get
annihilated by sound
and their clicks aren't just loud
they're incredibly complex leading some
scientists to believe sperm whales could
have a language more sophisticated than
our own sperm whales have haunted our
imaginations for Generations spurring
nightmares and sailors of centuries past
with their Impressions immortalized in
literature by Hermann Melville's Moby
Dick
a creature feared revered and long
misunderstood sperm whales have luckily
survived centuries of intensive and
brutal hunting
and now they're slowly beginning to
reveal the secrets of their Mysterious
World
1200 meters below the surface absolutely
no sunlight penetrates this zone of the
ocean is completely bathed in darkness
here pressure is 120 times that of the
surface a pressure is so high it would
kill most creatures
but this is also where a primordial
battle takes place a battle between
sperm whales and their giant squid prey
no person or camera has ever witnessed
such a hunt but sperm whales are
commonly found with circular scars from
a giant Squid's serrated suckers on the
end of its tentacles
the indigestible beaks and other body
parts of the giant squid also turn up in
the stomachs of sperm whales
to reach this darkest of hunting grounds
the sperm whale fills its lungs with one
final breath and begins to plunge
their bodies are well adapted to this
extreme environment where they spend
about 90 percent of their time
it's not only giant squid that bring
them to such great depths they also eat
deep sea sharks octopuses and cuttlefish
the stomach of one sperm whale was even
found to contain a species of dogfish
that lives three kilometers down on the
ocean floor making sperm whales one of
the deepest divers of the animal kingdom
but getting their massive bodies so deep
is a complicated process especially
since they're naturally buoyant
to deal with this sperm whales have
evolved something completely bizarre a
mysterious substance the one that gives
sperm whales their name
spermicidi oil which fills much of the
head cavity is normally warm and liquid
but when the whales dive it's thought
that the cool water solidifies it
allowing it to act almost like a diving
wage to pull the whales down
this helps explain how they can
physically get down there but how can
they survive it
as they descend the pressure becomes so
high the whale's lungs begin to collapse
at this point the rib cage hinges closed
around their collapsing lungs
squeezing most of the air into their
trachea so that there's less gas
exchange in the lungs protecting the
whales from nitrogen buildup
to compensate for not getting enough
oxygen from their lungs whales have a
much higher concentration of oxygen
containing molecules hemoglobin and
myoglobin then land dwelling mammals
having about twice as much hemoglobin as
humans and 10 times as much myoglobin
means that the whales are essentially
equipped with a built-in oxygen tank
even when they're not breathing for more
than an hour but that's not the only
thing helping them stay supplied with
oxygen
they also have clumps of blood vessels
near their brains called retia mirabelia
these vascular Nets help regulate blood
pressure and seem to keep the brain well
supplied with oxygen
meanwhile the heart rate slows in a
process called bradycardia slowing all
other physiological processes so the
body doesn't consume as much oxygen
that lower heart rate also limits gas
transport around the whale's body
and this is critical because of a
problem known as decompression sickness
aka the bends
when humans descend while scuba diving
nitrogen from the air dissolves into our
tissues
if we then Ascend to the surface too
quickly this dissolved nitrogen will
expand into bubbles in our tissue a
situation that for us can be extremely
dangerous or even fatal for a long time
scientists thought whales must be immune
to getting the bends because of their
physiology
their trachea is solidified by extra
rings of cartilage so that when air is
compressed there when they dive nitrogen
is stored rather than dissolved into the
whale's tissues surely that meant whales
couldn't suffer from decompression
sickness but a sad situation in 2002
proved that to be untrue
after a Navy sonar exercise 14 beaked
whales died after beaching themselves in
the Canary Islands
autopsies revealed that they all had gas
bubbles in their tissues Wales it turns
out are indeed susceptible to this
Insidious killer if they're forced to
ascend too quickly but scientists are
still investigating what might Force
whales to make a rapid Ascent besides
painful noises
they might also be chased up by
Predators or have some other Behavior we
don't understand or can easily observe
this inability to easily monitor what
sperm whales are doing at such great
depths is one reason that they're so
mysterious even something as basic as
their hunting methods is Up For Debate
it's not clear how the whales catch
their prey
sperm whales have teeth but only on
their lower jaw which means they're not
well suited to latching onto something
and though some species of whale have
teeth only in the males for fighting and
display purposes sperm whale males and
females both have teeth in one rare
video a sperm whale is seen removing
fish from long line fishing gear by
shaking the line with its teeth but not
touching the fish with its teeth these
kitchen knife-sized Chompers aren't
really used for chomping
so what are they for
it's a question that's been particularly
intriguing to Dr Joy reidenberg a
comparative anatomist and professor at
the icann school of medicine at Mount
Sinai in New York City
we do know from tracking devices that
they dive down and kind of hang out in
one area for a while and then come back
up so the assumption is that they're
rely on weight Predator that they're not
a Pursuit predator and if that's the
case that they go down and hang out
somewhere one of my favorite theories is
that they open their mouth and they
might have some bioluminescent bacteria
on their teeth or something that their
teeth glows and maybe attracts the squid
to the mouth and then they just suck it
into their mouth so the teeth may be
lures
we also know that they sometimes rake
the sea floor and use their teeth in
that way they that if they just stick
their mouth into the sand and swing
forward it's kind of like a plow that
plow is going to disturb things in the
sediment those little animals that then
think animals like crabs and shrimps and
stuff May jump up and get sucked into
the whale's mouth sperm whales have even
been found Tangled in the transatlantic
cables lying on the ocean floor either
because they were stirring up sediment
or maybe because they were attracted by
the electrical signals
it's hard to know for sure what sperm
whales are doing in the deep but during
the limited amount of time they spend
closer to the surface a few things
become very clear
namely that they have very large brains
and very complex social behaviors
sperm whales have the largest brains of
any living animal
and possibly of any animal to exist on
Earth ever at any point in time their
gray matter can be seven to nine
kilograms in weight about six times
larger than a human brain
researchers originally thought toothed
whales have such large brains because of
their echolocation after all the
non-ecco-locating blue whale is larger
than the sperm whale but its brain isn't
as big but more recent research in the
fossil record shows that large brains
came before the anatomy that allowed for
underwater echolocation the scientists
instead suggest that large brains and
citations are closely linked to their
social behavior
and sperm whales are indeed highly
social they live in matrilineal Clans
with calves suckling for up to 13 years
and all calves have a primary babysitter
apart from their mother so that the
mother can continue diving to hunt all
the members of a group of sperm whales
will assist with raising young but adult
males generally leave their families to
live more solitary lives
it was thought for years that these
adult males were some of the loneliest
creatures on the planet but more recent
research has found that many male sperm
whales actually spend a lot of time with
male friends whether it's migrating
feeding or sadly even stranding together
these social groups are tied together by
sound loud intricate and robust
vocalizations
but how exactly do they make such
complex sounds it all comes down to
their massive noses
Dr Joy reidenberg has been fascinated by
sperm whale vocalizations for her entire
career and she believes that of all
whales it's the sperm whale who has the
most impressive vocalizations
about one-third of the sperm whales body
length is its nose so it is the largest
nose in the animal kingdom
and that nose is a sound producer and a
big portion of that nose is what made
sperm whales so valued by Whalers that
waxy spermicidi it was used in candles
and ointments and wailing in pursuit of
it almost completely wiped sperm whales
off the face of the planet Whalers
called it spermicidi because they
thought it was sperm it was not and
honestly pretty weird that they thought
it was
as mentioned before spermicidi is
crucial in their buoyancy control and in
their communication
and the purpose for that oil is to take
the vibrations that are generated at the
very front of the sperm whale's head in
that boxy shape where air is brought to
the very front it goes through a pair of
large looking lips that are inside the
nose that click kind of like a pair of
castanets and as they click they vibrate
the tissue that is the lip and that lip
is attached to the spermicity organ and
it sends a vibrational wave propagating
through the spermicity organ until it
reaches the back of the head
where that click is then reflected off
of an air sac that's on the front of the
skull from there the sound is reflected
through a series of what might be
considered condensing filters where the
sound is modified to be either a sharp
beam or a low quiet Rumble and this part
of the whale has another stupid name and
that particular organ is called the junk
because it was not useful compared to
the spermicity oils but in fact it's
probably the most functional part of the
whole head because that's where the
sound is modified in some ways somehow
modulates the sound and that final sound
can be incredibly loud a sperm whale can
click about 236 decibels for reference
human eardrums burst at 150 decibels
our pain threshold is about 110 decibels
things like live rock music or jet
engines heard from a hundred feet away
our normal conversations are only about
60 decibels
sound travels differently in water than
in air so the decibel measurements
aren't exactly comparable but this is
still insanely loud it is by far the
loudest noise any animal can make
does that mean a sperm whale
vocalization could kill a human in the
water Dr ridenberg says there have been
no documented cases of this happening
but that doesn't mean it's totally
impossible luckily for us we're not the
sperm whale's favorite prey
if we were giant squid those Sonic
blasts might well cause some serious
damage
and the Sonic Blast is just one of the
many types of Extremely Loud Noises a
sperm whale can make
the big males have this sound that's
called the clang which is a very very
loud very intense uh you know sound it's
probably advertising that hey I'm in the
neighborhood come on ladies here I am
and then all the ladies come around and
gather around the the big male that has
swung through the neighborhood
um because it then becomes an orgy for
the whales uh and yet males are hardly
the only ones making such loud calls
sperm whales have many patterns of
clicks that make up their complex
language
the most common are clicks used for
long-range echolocation like sonar and
then there's close range Creeks for when
prey capture is eminent
and finally codas are distinct patterns
of clicks most often heard when whales
are socializing
and these vocalizations are of
particular interest to scientists
sperm whale codas sort of sound like
Morse code and the patterns of the
clicks are distinct among social groups
with each Clan having its own specific
repertoire of codas these codas are the
social glue that holds the Clans
together
females use codas more than males which
makes sense when you think about how
they raise their young
no it's probably social communication
it's probably communication with the
Cavs it's Communications with each other
they might simply be advertising how
deep they've gone so that the Catholic
can't follow them knows where the mother
is at all times even though the monks
farther away from the calf the depth
that the whale goes to will distort the
sound so by the time the calf hears it
it has some information about that
Distortion it tells it how deep the
mother has Dove and now we give it some
idea of anticipating when the mother is
coming back up again and more than just
signaling each other's location
researchers believe distinct Coda
repertoires represent their own unique
cultures
just as groups of people from different
sides of the world will speak eat and
dress differently clans of sperm whales
from different areas will behave
differently too and the more researchers
investigate these codas the more they
realize just how much information could
be packed into these patterns of sound
so much information that researchers are
starting to realize that sperm whale
language is perhaps as complex as our
own the first major hint that codas are
not just instinctual and arbitrary
noises is the fact that calves can take
up to two years to produce recognizable
codas and before that they Babble just
like human babies
and recently researchers realized that
not only do Clans use different codas
but the codas differ slightly among
individuals
this could be a way for each individual
to have a unique identifier AKA a name
the whales aren't just making noise they
are literally talking
when a group of researchers looked at
the historic recordings of whaling in
the 19th century they found that
successful Harpoon strikes dropped by
more than 50 percent after the first few
years of hunting that dramatic of a
change can't be attributed solely to the
skill of the Whalers
instead researchers think the sperm
whales were sharing strategies with one
another about how to evade capture sperm
whale codas may be the closest thing to
our language we have ever discovered
and this raises an interesting question
can we translate this language into
hours
in a future video we will discuss the
ongoing effort to create the first
inter-species Rosetta Stone using
machine learning
what's already clear to us is that sperm
whales have the loudest voices in the
animal kingdom
and they seem to be using them to say
quite a lot of different things
understanding whales is an Endeavor that
will take generations and an Endeavor
that will require utter dedication from
scientists who will stop at nothing to
collect the data that they need
but working with such large animals in
the field comes with its own immense
challenges it's sometimes messy most of
the time when I dissect the whale I feel
like I'm doing it from the inside out I
get in the whale and basically pushing
things out and sometimes harrowing I
just was so happy not to be dead stories
like these are sometimes hard to believe
but they are the reality for scientists
who spend their lives around these
spectacular animals and these stories
are the basis for our new nebula plus
series field notes I often talk about
the science of incredible animals on
this channel and now we will get to hear
from the experts behind the science the
people who spend months years or decades
in the field the people who know these
animals better than anyone else on the
planet and have some of the most
shocking funny and wild stories I have
ever heard the best way to watch this
episode of field notes on nebula and the
previous field notes episode about
sloths is to sign up to the Curiosity
stream and nebula bundle deal at
curiositystream.com real science
curiositystream has partnered with us so
you get both streaming services for the
price of one
curiosity stream is a streaming platform
with tons of high quality documentaries
like this episode of wild Caribbean
called Wales and volcanoes investigating
the surprising phenomenon of sperm
whales being attracted to areas with
colossal volcanic forces and nebula is
our streaming platform where we can
release new original content without
worrying about the YouTube algorithm
and right now you can get the bundle
deal for 42 off the usual price that's
just 11.59 for the entire year less than
a dollar a month to get access to all of
the original content nebula has to offer
and to support this channel plus it's a
great last minute holiday gift for any
documentary loving friends or family
so go to curiositystream.com real
science to get nebula and curiosity
stream for just 11.59 for the entire
year and if you're looking for something
else to watch right now you can watch
our last video about the surprising
reasons bioluminescence barely exists on
land or you can watch real engineering's
latest video about the explosive way
that seat belts work